joining me today to dish up some stories
is comedian writer and the amazing chloe
hillyard
yeah chloe before being a comic
goddess you were actually a journalist i
was i did that for many years and then i
realized people don't read
and so i started talking to a microphone
and he listened
all right let's get right into the news
shall we dive in let's start in the uk
where the ap reports that five
grey parrots had to be removed from
their enclosure at the zoo
for cursing at visitors yes
good news the naughty parrots weren't
kicked out but they were just separated
because when they were together they
kept egging each other on chloe
what are your thoughts free the birds
okay
you need to let them out first of all
the zoo business is not what it
was right and there are a lot of adults
who don't have children but they would
love to go to a zoo where they can
engage with cussing birds
i have to tell you this was one of my
favorite stories of the week
can you just imagine like a boozy brunch
at the zoo
and you get cussed at by birds
i would go in a hard night zoos
call us all right our next story is
something i'm sure we've all noticed
chloe you know how sometimes like people
in long-term relationships start to look
alike even celebrities have it like
check out i mean these pictures say it
all here's seth meyers and alexi ash
i mean they they look like you know
alike
um steph and aisha curry absolutely
just beautiful uh benedict cumberbatch
and sophie hunter
they yeah these this one dylan sprouse
and barbara paulvin
creepy it's like it's crazy they do look
like brother and sister
um jim parsons and todd spiwak
adorbs they both adorable i know my
cousins
denzel washington yes well okay so
stanford university did a study and they
say that the idea that couples start to
look alike
is really a myth that really
yahoo life reports that researchers
found that if a couple looks alike it's
because they started out that way
really yeah and scientists are call it
uh they call it a sort of mating and
people are often
attracted to people who look like
themselves yeah
i mean let's see what do you think chloe
what does my future husband look like
i see it i see it i feel it i'm like you
up
um okay what do you think of this just
in time for halloween dwell magazine
says the home of buffalo bill
the skin-wearing psychopath from the
silence of the lambs
could be yours listed as a rare
opportunity
the queen anne victorium from the movie
is listed for 298 000.500
and here's some of the photos of the
property showcasing amazing wood accents
but curiously
no photos of the basement
i think that is the selling point we are
in a pandemic time
i want a house with the pre-made bunker
show me the basement
all right well this is a weird story the
bbc uh reports on a wellness trend
that came from the dutch countryside and
it's
called kook nufellen and it means cow
cuddling
because when you cuddle a cow it says
that it really releases
oxytocin even more than hugging a dog
and this is a new phenomenon chloe
thoughts i wonder does
cow dunk smell better in dutch land than
it does in america
because i've smelled poo and i'm not
hugging it cow poo
is depleting the ozone i was just gonna
say it's not good for the environment
maybe we should hug
cows more than eat them hashtag meatless
monday oh okay go hug a cat
hashtag meet this monday but where do
you hug them like around the neck
is it yes around the neck so you want
they want us to choke cows for our
benefit
yes they want us to like we're all just
supposed to cling to animals right now
because you know
the world is a tough place so listen
you know what i think we really just
need each other
and at a six foot distance of course but
thank you chloe so much for coming on
the news i'm so grateful that you're
here it is
so hard to play next time i'll bring a
cow i love it
you